major je voulais évoquer un sujet sur
Saint-Laurent duaroni je pense que vous
connaissez qui est la commune
frontalière avec le Surinam et j'ai eu
un entretien avec le maire de la ville
et qui disait qu'elle était inquiète
parce qu'elle voyait des jeunes au
volant de gros cylindré et comme il y a
pas de Girs en Guyane en dépend de la
Martinique et elle me demandait elle me
disait quels sont les moyens dont
dispose la gendarmerie parce qu'elle a
l'impression que Ben ces situations se
multiplie donc des jeunes des fois même
ils n'ont pas le permis ils ont 17 ans
ils roulent des des Q7 des Mercedes
coupés des voitures que nous je pense
qu'on aurait pas eu l'idée d'acheter et
eux il roul elle disait que je sais que
ces gamins sont issus de famille
défavorisé et puis qu' se balade à
Saint-Laurent au volant de ses véhicules
et elle pense que c'est l'objet en tout
cas c'est est produit de de de trafic de
stupéfiant donc elle disait quell sont
son les moyens mis à la disposition des
gendarmes de la commune de enfin de la
ville de Saint-Laurent du Maroni
concrètement pourevenenir sur la sur la
Guyane nous avons nous avons fortement
renforcé les moyens depis et pas
uniquement sur le l'effet de pour le de
lutte contre l'orpaillage clandestin
hein nous avons depuis plus d'un an
envoyé une Task Force police judiciaire
pour renforcer les effectif et notamment
la Section de Recherche sur place ayant
conscience que dans ce dans ce ce B
terit j'ai eu la chance d'aller à
Saint-Laurent du Maroni et à
saint-georgees de leyapoc mais j'étais
beaucoup plus jeune mais c'était je
garde des souvenirs émus de ce momentl
de ces momentsl mais au-delà de mes
souvenirs
pardon c'est vrai bon il y a une
porosité des frontières on traversef on
fait il suffit d'y aller une fois on
traverse le fleuve enfin les deux de
part et d'autre on a une porosité une
complexité dans dans le contrôle qui qui
qui sera il n'y aura jamais d'étanchéité
c'est je parle même pas de de la la
frontière en forêt hein donc il n aura
jamais d'étanchéité donc il est
important d'agir effectivement sur sur
les sur les personnes sur notre volonté
parfois de de renforcer de donner auprès
du chef territorial d'autres moyens
c'est ce que l'on a expérimenté outreem
en Guyane et à Mayotte et on s'est rendu
compte que ça marche c'est que c'est le
chef territorial qui identifie alors
parfois localement ça peut
être effectivement un train de vie qui
est différent on on identifie des choses
mais parfois foit ces unités qui ont qui
ont un modèle un format et non'ont pas
ne peuvent pas toujours aller plus vite
que la procédure le permet donc c'est
eux qui identifient leur priorité et
nous on leur envoie des moyens
d'enquêteur et s'ils ont besoin la voie
de simple OPJ entre guillemets pour
simple mais d'OPJ pour acter plus vite
ou de technicien de haut niveau pour
faire des recoupements du travail du
travail de téléphonie enfin on les met à
disposition du chef local pour pouvoir
mieux traiter ce que lui a identifié et
c'est ce qu'on essaie de développer avec
euh alors ce qu'on a fait avec la Task
Force en guyan